this boy bears wind
snaps placement down by O'Donnell
[Applause]
as time expires
17:16 chargers the wind photosphere
that was a moment on Sunday that defeat
was snatched from the jaws of victory at
Soldier Field it looked like the Bears
were gonna win the game and Eddie Panero
goes just wide laughs big cat is it
better or worse than it wasn't a doink
it what we already had a doink earlier
in the game so Eddie Pena already
doinked one earlier in the game one that
was closer it's better that it was not a
doink
yes it was better okay so people like
you the simple minds in the world can't
keep making the same joke over and over
thinking it's funny ha ha ok so here's
what's not funny the strategy that
preceded the kick because Matt naggy
chose not to try to get more yardage to
move the kick closer
newsflash the closer the kick is the
easier it is to make naggy refused to do
that taking a knee instead and actually
moving the kick back a little bit making
it that 41-yard try that ultimately have
the game riding on it make it and you
win miss it and you lose and naggy said
he gave zero thought to doing anything
other but the other than taking knee
that was on Sunday on Monday after he
had a chance to sleep on it
naggy addressed it again here he is
doubling down on the decision to do
things exactly the way he did him and he
would never do it any differently here's
Matt nagging it's not about trust it's
just about it's about playing smart it's
a 40-yard field goal think about that ok
that doesn't it takes nothing away from
Panero we love Eddie we got all the
faith in the world in him we know he's
gonna bounce back ask anybody on the
team it's it's the NFL it happens how do
you how do you respond to it right how
do you respond to it so I I really it's
it's to me I'm very very comfortable
knowing what I did I'm very very
comfortable knowing if I'm in that exact
situation again ok
at that same yard line I'm gonna do the
same thing see that's the thing that
concerns me about coaching I think for
any aspect of the game if you have an
inflexibility
if you have no consideration for
variables that may cause you to look at
different situations differently
if you say this is the way I'm always
gonna do something just because I don't
wanna I don't know I don't want to
revisit it I don't want to clutter my
mind with these aren't that difficult of
decisions you have to be willing to
factor in everything and maybe sometimes
it is the smart thing to take a knee
sometimes it's smart thing to try to get
it closer but I think when it comes to a
field goal it's always smart to try to
get it closer I know yeah you run that
ball you're taking the chance there's
gonna be a fumble or there's gonna be
some other screwy thing that happens
that knocks you back even farther I get
that but when I I just I don't like the
inflexibility big cat I you know I did
it and I will always do it now never
change no matter what I just don't like
that that's not an acceptable
explanation especially when something
went poorly it's the inflexibility and
Mike that that soundbite you just played
it's so clear that Matt Nagy is kind of
cracking here because he's trying to
basically push the blame to Eddie Panero
saying repeating the fact hey it's a
40-yard field goal does the NFL you
should make a 40-yard field goal yeah
you should but you know what's better
than a 40-yard field goal a 35-yard
field goal wouldn't happen timeout and
you so here's my biggest problem with
what Matt Negi said after the game with
what he's doubling down with he one does
not trust his offense it's so clear the
fact that he cannot say when he says
well they know you're gonna run so you
can't get three or four yards says who
put your best goal line put your best
goal line offense in there run the ball
you know had on hat you've run the ball
for 135 yards David Montgomery had on
Sunday they were able to push him around
they had time of possession by about ten
minutes they had the Chargers defense
gassed they could have gotten three or
four yards running okay so don't run the
ball that's fine if you want to go with
that if they know you're running then
pass the ball if they know you're
running you can throw the ball you have
a timeout in your pocket you do not
trust mr. Biscay and that is very clear
and then finally Mike the last point
here he completely contradicted himself
in his own statements and the fact that
he's doubling down on his contradiction
is absolutely insane
Mike I'm reading the exact words that
Matt naggy said after the game he said
we were in field goal range before the
scramble and then we got the scramble so
that didn't even cross my mind talking
about running the football so if you
remembered
the sequence [ __ ] sure Biscay runs for
I think it was an 11 yard scramble gets
closer then they kneel the ball and call
a timeout so when someone when a
reporter asked why wouldn't you throw
the ball or run the ball he says what
happens if you take a sack or there's a
fumble you lose the game but if you're
already in field goal range how do you
lose the game with a sack Mike you have
a timeout so he contradicted himself if
you're already in field goal range
before the scramble then you get the
scramble and you now are not gonna run a
pass play because you might take a sack
and get out of field goal range
you've contradicted yourself you're
doing doublespeak here and so in that
Nagy I think to me he's a good coach but
he's kind of cracking here and and
things have gone sideways for him and
mr. Biscay is not the guy and we know
mr. Biscay is not the guy which by the
way that's partially matt Nagy's fault
because he was brought in to make mr.
Biscay the guy so when we all bash mr.
Biscay and he deserves a lot of you know
people saying he's not the guy and he's
not gonna ever be him because I think
we've seen enough that we know that Matt
Nagy should be in that pile too because
he was the guy who was brought in to
make Michnik mr. Biscay a competent
above average quarterback and it hasn't
happened I just think that the guy is
Matt Nagy's cracking he is panicking you
saw in the first half when when the team
is down at the goal line and they
completely botched the goal line first
half offense I've never seen anything
like that it's this little things to
Mike the the offensive linemen not being
able to get up off the field and getting
back to the ball fast enough to call in
a couple plays they're not getting
spikes off not running the ball on third
and nine from third and goal from the 9
yard line it's it all just feels like
panicky moves and and they have to
figure out a way to get this back on
track because it's teetering right now
Mike it's teetering and it feels late so
it all go really bad this reminds me of
the scene from Hard Knocks last year the
huge accident Todd Haley conversation
about when and how you use players in
training camp and the line from Todd
Haley was we can't reserve
in our fears and I feel like Matt naggy
has taken full and complete residents in
his fear and he's afraid of everything
and every decision he makes is
calculated to avoid a mistake to avoid a
turnover to avoid a sack to avoid
something he can be criticized for later
how else do you justify when you snap
the ball second and goal from the one at
the end of the second quarter with 25
seconds on the clock and the play goes
one-yard and you don't try to call
another play and you let it bleed all
the way down to one second before you
spike it to kick a field goal who does
that
I'll tell you who does that somebody who
has bought real estate in his fears and
that's where he is and everything now is
motivated by avoiding that thing that is
gonna come back to haunt him and as a
result everything is coming back to
haunt and the Code eparchy thing last
year I think really did have an effect
on him because you saw it when he did
the kicking competitions every single
day in the spring and everyone had to
line up and kick a 43-yard field goal
and everyone had to watch and it's it's
the inability to move on and in you're
right playing in your fears here feels
like it's it's kind of taking a toll on
Matt Nagy's decision-making and look if
you don't trust mr. Biscay you need to
then put in chase Daniel because you
can't win not trusting the quarterback
and it's pretty clear you don't trust
them when you make decisions like this
Mike the last thing I'll say and I'm
obviously very fired up because I want
them to succeed and I want Matt Nagy to
be the guy because here's here's really
what it comes down to mr. Biscay I think
everyone knows the Bears are probably
gonna at least bring in competition next
year for mr. Biscay if not you know move
on fully from him if Matt nagi's also
mistake the Bears are in big trouble
because then that means that Ryan pace
has kind of screwed up his two biggest
decisions in the quarterback and the
coach and yeah he deserves a lot of
credit for what he's done with his
defense but if you don't have a
quarterback in a coach you don't have
anything so this is this is why I say
it's teetering and in it made it reminds
me
Marc Trestman in 2013 you will remember
this Mike because it came against your
Vikings remember when he kicked on 2nd
down with Robbie Gould and everyone
second-guessed that and it felt like
everything kind of shifted from there
and and all the bad vibes came in and
the second guessing that's where you
feel right now with the teetering and it
doesn't feel like Matt nagi's really up
for the job especially handling the
media I think he's just being so defiant
that at some point yet say just admit
you made a mistake just you know don't
be so adversarial with the media always
just answer the question and don't don't
say you're not gonna get into it and you
would never make it a different decision
be honest it's ok it's ok we talked
about this with Bryan footage be honest
sometimes with the media it goes a long
way let me ask you this question before
we take our break if Mitch true Biscay
were to be benched right is that
something Matt naggy can do without Ryan
pace is blessing because at some point
pace is invested in this cuz he's the
guy who traded up a spot with Patrick
mahomes and deshaun Watson on the board
sorry to mention that but I had to he's
the guy that made the true Biscay
decision before Matt naggy was even
employed by the Bears could naggy have
that power to bench true Biscay without
pay signing off on it that's a good
question I you know when it comes to
these decisions I just assume everyone
is just trying to keep their job so Matt
naggy right now is probably saying look
it's Ryan paces guy I can push him off I
can say that's Ryan paces guy I'm
dealing with what I've been dealt here
like you know mr. Biscay was put on me
even though that's not really how it
worked because Matt Negi came to Chicago
after mr. burski was drafted so he
clearly in the meeting sold them that he
could be the guy to make mr. Biscay
great which is something we've kind of
and oh yeah by the way Mike he was also
on the coaching staff when that draft
went down with the Kansas City Chiefs
and the Chiefs traded up for Patrick
mahomes so I would I would guess that
Matt naggy like Patrick mahomes and
deshaun Watson a lot more than mr.
Biscay in that draft so then him doing
an interview and saying oh yeah I love
mr. Biscay I you know I think I can be
the guy to change him he deserves blamed
for that but to answer
your question I honestly don't know and
it's a it's a situation that I'm worried
about because the whole thing feels
doesn't it feel like we're teetering on
a little bit of everything falling apart
yeah we are and one year after an NFC
North championship you know what that
didn't say Ben McAdoo he was in the
playoffs one year and he was gone in the
middle of the next season
here's another dynamic to consider big
cat with this Matt naggy Chicago Bears
Ryan pay situation as this thing begins
to fall apart I think your instincts are
accurate it feels like it's falling
apart just a year after the Bears won
the NFC North championship this is when
we get into the stuff that may be going
on behind the scenes between pace and
naggy because they're gonna start
blaming each other even though naggy is
a pace higher and its paces second
higher and chances are if naggy goes
pace goes to naggy could be making the
power play behind the scenes naggy could
be the one saying I took the team to the
NFC North championship last year without
guys that I picked if I just had a
little more say in the quarterback let
me pick a quarterback let me have a
quarterback maybe we need a different GM
maybe we need you know there's different
subtle ways that this stuff plays out
it's part of the dysfunction that can
descend on a football team when the GM
and the coach aren't tied at the hip
like they should be and that's the next
phase to watch of this because if nag is
cracking up externally he's cracking up
internally and he may be thinking about
doing anything he can to protect himself
and that wouldn't include trying to
undermine the guy who gave him Mitchell
true Biscay and to add on all that Mike
the Bears don't have a lot of draft
picks if you look at it they have to
second second rounders this year they
have no first-round right I think they
have no third or fourth rounder so when
you talk about turning pages and adding
talent and having everyone feel like
there's a fresh start it's going to be
hard to do that when you don't have the
draft capital and there's not
compensatory picks coming so it's I'm
just nervous about the whole thing it
feels like everything that was good last
year has completely turned and from the
double dunk I know who joke about it and
I'm so sick of hearing about the double
doink
but the double doink
was you know the nail in the coffin as
it is right now of this regime because
they have to figure it out and they have
to figure it out fast and that makes
what the Saints have done the past
couple of years even more impressive
they shrugged off the Minneapolis
miracle they shrugged off that horrible
call in the NFC Championship game and
here they are seven and one two by all
indications ready to have their hearts
broken in the playoffs again we'll be
right back
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports